it's great to welcome back to the
program bill scher who is contributing
editor to Politico magazine bill has
caught the ire actually of some in our
audience but will maybe get to that
later or maybe it'll just sort of
surface naturally during the
conversation bill so let's talk a little
bit about midterm strategy we're now
about 10 months away from the November 6
midterm elections there are a lot of
different lines of interest in these
particular midterms specifically because
of Donald Trump as president of the u.s.
generally speaking what's your outlook
on these midterms for the left
well the outlook is very good it almost
in most special elections in 2017 the
ones that have been more nationally
well-known like the Doug Jones race in
Alabama
well the John also phrase in Georgia as
well as you further down ballot you know
state of local races Democratic turnout
has been above the baseline and
Republican turnout has been below the
baseline so even races where Republicans
won like that Georgia race with John
Asaf the Democratic decline from 2006
was much less than what you saw on the
Republican side so if that pattern holds
in 2018 when the races are going to be
even the house map I mean none of the
maps are super favorable Democrats mind
you but if you have a similar pattern of
weak Republican turnout a strong
Democratic turnout it should be a very
good year yes so in terms of patterns I
mean when we talk about midterms during
the first midterm for a for a president
so to speak the the sort of rule of
thumb is it's good for the party not in
the white house in 2002 for George W
Bush post 9/11 that was an exception to
that rule but generally speaking that's
that's a bit of conventional wisdom
turnout is also typically significantly
lower for these midterms than in
presidential elections is there
something in particular other than just
the craziness sort of caused by the
Trump era that you think might reverse
some of those trends or exacerbate them
in 2018
well it's typical for the out party to
have good midterms the end party the
party in power has to govern governing
requires trade-offs that tend to depress
some elements of the governing party's
base and the out party is just mad at
whatever the in party is doing and so
they're energized so Obama had two
terrible midterms it's I think it's
somewhat typical for there to be some
kind of mitigating factor in one of your
two midterms so for George Bush as you
said 2002 was pretty good for
Republicans that was post 9/11 by 2006
the wear and tear of being the party in
power finally caught up with Republicans
and Democrats had a wave year that
brought Nancy Pelosi into the speaker's
chair in 1994 Bill Clinton had a
terrible first two years he couldn't get
a stimulus pass he passed the tax
increase that was a backtrack from his
middle-class tax cut pledge Hillary care
was a disaster the crime bill was very
was very unpopular terrible 1994 Newt
Gingrich becomes Speaker 1998 there's
impeachment and there's a pro Clinton
backlash to the impeachment that's a
pretty good midterm year for for
Democrats so in so far this year there's
no mitigating circumstance that's going
to help Trump the Republicans stave off
a bad midterms so far maybe something
happens between now and November that I
can't can't foresee but it Trump's
approval has been so bad for so long I
very little seems to actually move the
needle he bounces between you know mid
30s and low 40s anything within that
range is theoretically bad for
Republicans writ large so it helped you
something pretty dramatic to help
Republicans avoid a bad midterm year
okay so then now let's get more into the
micro of the strategy with the different
types of races that Democrats might find
themselves facing and I think this is
where I'm seeing post on our subreddit
from people very very displeased with
bill scher as the staff here knows there
have been a couple different movements
that have cropped up over the last
couple of years bill as I
no you know that have a focus not on
flipping red seats blue but on primary
anybody within the Democratic Party that
is identified as not to the left enough
and my general view has been that's a
great idea but let's be cautious and and
sort of prudent with that strategy
because that's a strategy that in some
cases in a world with limited resources
that one can spend on any one election
it could end up actually turning some
blue seats red so let me just first say
only that and turn it over to you what's
your sense of these movements that seem
to be pushing in some cases the prime
area of Democrats that they don't see as
to the left enough at the possible risk
of giving Republicans a win well let me
be clear I feel I write a lot of things
on the subject that get twisted around
all the intertubes ii-i've never argued
that Democrats should only run
right-leaning candidates or you know I I
wrote a piece called urge to purge it
was critical of the decision to have a
left wing challenge to Dianne Feinstein
in in California as a distraction of
resources now it's very possible that
Kevin de Leon who is the main guy who's
running against the fines that he could
win I'm not saying he can't win and
there's another piece I wrote after Doug
Jones won Alabama which is maybe this is
a time for a generic Democrats you faced
off against Donald Trump in 2020 and
that got twist around to saying bill
scher wants centrist or center-right
Candy's right that's not generic that's
that's that's taking a more distinctive
ideological path which dojos did not do
you know doug jones didn't run as an
anti-abortion democrat or a die-hard
pro-gun democrat and and even that
article was an argument for what
democrats should do up and down the
ballot that was what's gonna make sense
to match up with donald trump in 2020
and that's it not a template for the
party forevermore so i think you got to
be very specific in what kind of race
you're talking about right it may well
be that if you ran an army of
progressive populist
candidates across the country in 2018
that they would do very well but it's
also possible you can run a bunch of
bland flavorless candidates in 2080 and
they might do very well also so the and
I'm and you're not gonna have that kind
of simple control you do one thing one
time and you assess it it's probably a
mix of candidates in 2018 and maybe
we'll be able to tease out better
who has the edge in this ideological
battle for 2020 which I think is gonna
get played out in the presidential
primary no matter what but if you were
like I assume any of your audience in
believing fervently that a progressive
populist Bernie Kratt democratic
socialist candidate is the only way to
win races in red leaning areas I think
there are some contrary data points from
2017 Rob Quist ran as a Bernie Kratt in
Montana and lost although did better
than the previous House candidate that
year but Steve Bullock is the governor
of Montana and he won in 2016 and he is
not a Bernie creddies much more of a
moderate yeah and I think that's why you
know my approach has been and it sounds
like it's similar to what you're saying
although may be worded differently which
is you have to understand the context
and often the one that comes up is Joe
Manchin right Joe Manchin in West
Virginia really really popular
understandably popular to bash him as
arguably the most right-leaning
Democratic senator period and I've
pointed out that you don't have
unlimited resources and so if you want
to challenge if you want a primary
mansion you might end up blowing a bunch
of money and mansion still wins the
primary you might win the primary
against mansion and then you end up
turning that seat over to a real right
when ring Republican which there's no
shortage of in West Virginia to begin
with maybe that money is better spent
trying to flip a couple of congressional
seats or something like that and some
people understand that pragmatic
approach and some people just get
furious with me about it well you know
the magic there is a primary challenger
to mansion yeah I don't think that
person's give very much attention right
not it hasn't been an actual resource
drain and I think the argument that a
left-wing candidate is poised to win in
West Virginia if only given the chance I
don't really see a lot of evidence for
that based on what has happened at West
Virginia over the past several decades
yeah now you look at and you look at the
rent look what happened in the red areas
in 2017 you some people say well Zephyr
Teachout in 2016
didn't win upstate New York because
Hillary was a drag on the ticket and and
russ feingold couldn't win in Wisconsin
as Hillary was a drag on the ticket well
that's not true for Steve Bullock Steve
Bullock one of Montana anyway and Rob
Chris couldn't win until he was not on
the ticket doug jones again not a
right-wing Democrat but not a left-wing
democrat either and yes he really is the
pedophile Alabama I'm not saying that's
not an important data point to look at
here but he was able to energize he kept
that Democratic base revved not so much
because of him because the other guy was
so bad when the argument against running
bland flavorless candidate says that's
not good enough no matter how bad your
opponent is Hillary couldn't beat Donald
Trump well Doug George did beat worry
more so depending on your candidate your
opposing candidate maybe that is gonna
be good enough and maybe being a single
payer can't in a red state is not magic
to winning over Trump voters maybe
there's gonna be examples that disprove
that I mean not everything is gonna be
cut and dry but we haven't seen excuse
me we haven't seen Evans in 2017 that
the Bernie crap model is come how
impervious to Republican assault so
we're gonna have more test case than
2018 to look at last thing I want to
touch on the tax plan okay I am very
very worried that Trump and his cronies
will successfully sell the fact that a
tax plan was done rather than exactly
how it will affect voters as a success
as a campaign promise done and that it
will be tough for Democrats to actually
argue against that not because the facts
aren't with them but because the optics
of it are going to be favorable to
Republicans what do you think I think
both party
I think the Republicans are over selling
the tax bill and Democrats are under
selling the tax well insofar as the
political landscape it's concern for
2018 when Republicans are saying in
trouble literally said this is a massive
Christmas gift for you and that's not
really true
it has uneven impact across the country
depending on your income bracket and how
you itemize and all that sort of thing
it's not like a bush style tax cut but
if you remember from the Bush years
every got a three dollar check or most
people got three dollar check right and
Democrats would say this is crumbs the
top 1% are getting tens of thousands of
dollars and you're skating this pivotal
check and the response was you are being
really condescending to the working men
and women of this country who were
appreciate that $300 so stop being so
dismissive of the amount the and that
was and that was a winning political
counter-attack to Democrats in 2004 now
the Obama years had its own tactical the
making work pay tax credit which wasn't
a standalone check it was simply your
withholding was not was taken out of
your paycheck week to week and the Obama
economist said that's actually better
for the economy be more stimulative if
people get a check they stick in the
bank they don't spend it if it's a
little bit every week they're more lucky
to spend it they'll have a collective
teensie an effect on the economy this
tax cut is like Obama's tax cut in that
respect yes in no way if I believe
February first the new tax brackets go
into play and people who would be saving
money would immediately see more money
in their paychecks of varying amounts
the same thing yep
so there's gonna be a subtle difference
in people's paychecks this year which
people may or may not notice and they
also have to wonder what's gonna happen
when I actually do my tax returns in
April of 2019 which isn't gonna be
happening before the midterms maybe my
itemization aren't gonna work out in my
favor right depending on what what has
transpired in other parts of the tax cut
what happens
my health insurance premiums now that
the individual mandate has been
nullified only though technically not
nullified until 2019 but do health
insurance companies check up their
premiums in advance that we don't know
what do states and cities do in response
to this are there other property tax
increases that are going to occur people
don't distinguish between tax cuts you
look at their net on November 2018 what
is my overall cost of living as a result
of Trump's policies let all hypothetical
let's say Trump pulls out of NAFTA
between now and then does that cause a
price shock at the grocery store
you're not gonna say thanks for my 20
bucks am i withholding but now my
grocery bills 20% higher you haven't you
haven't really helped me out very much
there's so many uncertainties here that
I don't think we know that that's
dangerous for Republicans Democrats are
starting to oversimplify the case and
say this is a tax cut for the wealthy
and a tax increase the middle class
that's only true I mean there's
individual examples immediately again
depending on your circumstance but the
larger case is the individual tax cuts
expire in 2025 for individuals and not
for corporations right nobody cares
about 2025 and 2018 the tax codes gonna
change probably multiple times between
now and then people wanna know what is
their deal now where does Trump
delivered for me today and you're
telling people you're gonna get a tax
increase and they don't right away then
you're the person who's overshot Wow
bill scher you've said it all
contributing editor to Politico magazine
we'll keep checking in with you as we
close in on November 6 thanks as always
always a pleasure